but it's time for new rules everybody
all right no someone has to tell the
woman who claims to have cosmetically
added a third breast so as to drive away
men
that many people actually find three
boob fascinating how else can you
explain the popularity of Fox and
Friends
new rule now that the Jewish holidays
are upon us Judaic scholars must get
flame to me why you never see Chinese
people going out for Jewish food you
don't see that new rule someone has to
tell the Kurdish pesh MERGA forces not
now for sexy time come on guys so we
fighting Isis or picking up Persian
girls at the Beverly Center sunglasses
by DKNY machine gun by CIA near your new
rule if you're one of the nine people
who have complained that their new
iPhone six-plus got bent in their back
pocket you have to consider that maybe
you just have a great big fat ass
don't complain to Apple eat one
and by the way whoever is behind the
fake Apple ads claiming you can recharge
your new iPhone by heating it in a
microwave all you're doing is ruining
some people's phone and breaking their
microwaves and then how they're gonna
dry off the cat
trust me Apple fans this doesn't work
although you can't recharge your phone
by shoving it up your ass while you
stick your finger in a light socket that
does new rule give Alaska props for
being home to this chick first of all
she's a black weather lady in Alaska
where does she even get her hair done
secondly she owns a pot store and did
this will be dedicating all of my energy
toward fighting for freedom and fairness
which begins with legalizing marijuana
here in Alaska and as for this job well
not but I have a choice but [ __ ] it I
quit
oh honey you had me at hello you didn't
have to tell us about the quitting it's
Alaska everybody quit